One track you might want to take in
this course is a track on research.
Research is contributing to
human's broader understanding of
some phenomenon.
Or in this class, contributing to our
understanding of education and learning.
For example, you might want to
investigate how a particular tool
changes the learning process.
Or maybe you want to investigate how
different demographics or backgrounds
change a person's perceptions of
an online program like this one.
But research is very much it's own
language, it's own community and
in order to participate in research,
there's a lot you need to understand.
This is going to be a kind of a crash
course in everything you need to do
research, at least at
the level we're looking at.
We'll talk about some of
the vocabulary of research.
We'll talk about validity and
reliability and
some of the things you need to
be aware of during research.
And especially, we'll talk about
different research designs.
How to set up an experiment or
set up some research that
will actually answer the questions
that you want to answer.